في هذه القصور المهجوره التي كانت او
مازالت على ملك نخبه المجتمع السوري تبلغ
معركه اوجه في اكبر مدن هذا البلد نحن على
اطراف حلب في قريه حندرات اخر ممر متبق
للمقاتلين في المدينه ولو قدر ان استولت
قوات الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد على هذه
القريه فسيحا سر عشرات الالاف من
المعارضين يدل المقاتلون مصورنا على مواقع
النظام والان هاهم يبدون هجوما مباغتا على
مدى هذه الحقول المفتوحه يوجد شباب يلهثون
بفعل الارهاق وتعلو شفاههم علامات التعب
ولكن في حرب مدمره مثل هذا فان هذا يعد
مجرد تجربه والكثيرون لا يستمرون طويلا
فيها اخذن مننا بسبب تخاذل بعض الدول
العربيه بامداد بالسلاح وايران
تدعم جيش بشار
علن خلي يفرحوا حالهم هلا لانه الدور جاي
عليهم ل انهم عبارات على مجموعه بسيطه
مقارنه بقوات النظام المؤهله والمجهز
تماما فحتى بعد ثلاث سنوات من الحرب
مازالوا يقاتلون باسلحه بدائيه
وخفيفه كنت جاهز ن
[تصفيق]
شباب
رب ورمال
تمام نحن هون استخدمنا كله عباره عن
بواريد كلاش كو ورشاش خفيف خفيف بي سي وار
بيجي ها الاسلحه المستخدمه بجيش الحر كلها
اسلحه خفيفه ضد اسلحه دمار شامل ما عمنا
شي واننا عننا بس رب العالمين هو اللي عم
يساعدنا وينصرنا على هالنظام وعال الدول
كلها تكبير الله اكبر لقد قاموا باخذ
المصور الى خط امامي اخر يقع بالقرب من
المطار معقل اخر تابعا للنظام في
حلب
هذا هو اسلوب حياتهم اليومي كر وفر مثل
معارك القط والفار وسط حطام ما كان عالما
قديما والذي يعكس الشلل التام الذي اصاب
ما كان يعد مركز التجاره الابرز في البلاد
وذلك منذ سنتين انهم يطلقون النار على قوه
النظام وهذا الصوت هو اعاده اطلاق تلك
القوات للنار ولكن باسلحه اثقل
[موسيقى]
طل وهذا موقع اطلاق النار من خلاله يمكنكم
رؤيه ما
يحدث وقد رجع مرشدنا بعد ان مرت رصاصه
بالقرب من وجهه لا
تمك اخوي لان على العول عصوره م